good evening a golden knights coach
testing positive for covet 19
adding to what has been a very memorable
night for the team thanks for joining us
here at 11 o'clock i'm denise valdez and
i'm brian loftis the vegas golden
knights facing some unique obstacles in
tonight's game against the blues
not only were they facing former
champions they had an entirely different
lineup of coaches
sports director chris matthews is here
now with the shake up at t-mobile arena
chris
all right thank you guys yeah this is a
first and then first for an entire staff
in the nhl to be isolated
because of covid concerns might not ever
happen again perhaps it could again with
this covenant stuff
peter de boerner's group giving way to
general manager kelly mccrimmon and the
silver night staff
it had been a long time since mccrearman
had been behind the bench
but called upon to help the knights beat
the blues after vegas scores in the
first year blues come back with three
unanswered two of those by former knight
david perron robin leonard a little
shaky early on here annette but
they could have blown this team out
listen to that they hit the post six
times you hear that ping
vegas playing catch up it's max pacquiao
scoring three times
the hat trick for patches his seventh
career hattie it was shaping up to be a
magical night perhaps to come back and
win this thing
well almost in regulation they forced to
go to a shootout
and st louis scores now forcing alex
tuck
to keep hopes alive but he mishandles
the puck blues get the 5-4 win vegas had
46 shots on goal compared to 25 for the
blues
shot attempts vegas clearly dominated
83-48
but they come up short on the board with
the coaching staff that had never worked
a game together
it's not a case where the entire staff
tested positive there was
uh most that didn't uh quite frankly but
the protocol um
you know is is such that you
uh you know pull those people from the
group we're fortunate there's been no
positive tests for
for players all right because of the
positive tests and the precautions the
knights shut down
city national for tomorrow there will be
no practice
now the same two teams meet again on
thursday and according to mccrimmon
there is no indication thursday's game
will be postponed
you'll hear from the knights on this odd
night coming up in sports